[Musique]
où
quand on regarde une cigarette petits
morceaux boulant comme ça un peu bizarre
les abcès chez une odeur âcre
qui est qui relie d2 d'inspirer de la
fumée c'est comme si c'est comme si on
allait sniffer les pots d'échappement
on sait qu'il ya un truc un peu bizarre
comme un cigare
pis elle je vous déjà fumé comme tout le
monde
bien sûr mais c'est pas pour ce que ça
apporte
c'est un excitant la nicotine ce sacre
est plutôt du stress ces petites pauses
de c'est vrai un sarong pas forcément
très amoureux s'invente pas de bien être
encore quand on boit un verre de vin
faut le faire avec modération bien sûr
pour invité à boire du vin mais est un
petit peu petit peu de joie de lâcher
prise désinhibe avec la cigarette et pas
grand chose et pourtant sans accrocher à
ça soit une passion quand je travaille
avec eux sur l'arrêt de la cia teinte
cigarette comme leur meilleur ennemi et
c'est quelque chose aussi détonnant
ainsi arrête
si vous prenez un patch de nicotine
votre besoin en nicotine besoins
physiologiques si les drogues ça va ça
compense le besoin de cette drogue
et pourtant quand une personne utilise
des patchs qui n'arrive pas à arrêter
certains arrêtent et où le tiers
commence
et l'essentiel de la dépendance sur cinq
jours pourrait se dire au bout de cinq
jours tout est bien il y aura plus de
ceci on s'était passé de la substance
maintenant il ya des rechutes il ya
beaucoup de rechute et ses deux gros
problème de la plupart des méthodes pour
arrêter la cigarette c'est que bien
souvent ça aide les fumeurs à arrêter
mais qui payera des reprises a
heureusement est quelque chose de
positif c'est que plus on s'arrête deux
fois plus statistiquement on s'approche
d'une réussite totale que faut accepter
les chèques mais surtout il faut mieux
faire je mieux faire c'est pas si
compliqué que ça
pour bien construire son arrêt de la
cigarette
ce qui est le but de cette séance
d'hypnose a répété le plus haut possible
si possible à chaque fois vous fait il
est important de poule en compte les
bénéfices secondaires
c'est pas un gros mot le bénéfice
gondard nir est du jargon les bénéfices
secondaires c'est ce que vous apporte la
siphat la cigarette pour beaucoup de
personnes
c'est un moyen de se déstresser alors
c'est un peu une arnaque parce que comme
je vous le disais tout à l'heure c'est
un excitant quand on prend la cigarette
ont fait taire le stress créé par l aps
à la cigarette un peu le serpent qui se
mord la queue
c'est vrai quand on fume on sent un
soulagement et puis souvent quand on
fume prend un temps pour soi s'accorde
des pauses s'il veut pas de cigarettes
prendrait pas de pause quand on a une
vie prenantes
entre le travail les enfants la famille
les études etc
la cigarette ça permet voilà d'avoir un
temps pour soi de se faire plaisir bien
souvent quand on demande à des fumeurs
et qu'est ce que vous faites en dehors
de la cigarette pour vous faire plaisir
eh bien ils sont bien en peine pour
répondre et quand dans la classique at
il faut pas s'étonner qu'il prise de
poids après parce que ce qu'on perd
comme plaisir je men et fils secondaire
de la cigarette on retrouve dans la
bouffe passe de la clope à la bouffe et
si je le parle de clapet de bouffe c'est
celle à dessein parce que c'est un
rapport tellement familiers avec ces
substances
donc la séance d'hypnose coup à faire
aujourd'hui elle va prendre à rebours
tout ce que vous avez pu faire
pour travailler contre la cigarette le
but ça va être de construire au fur et à
mesure une cigarette après l'autre de
jour en jour de semaine en semaine
l'arrêt de votre cigarette de le faire
pour une fois sans violence
parce que si on arrête avec violence on
reprendra avec fracas sa marche fois ci
arrête ça marche pour les joints ça
marche pour la nourriture les régimes se
marchent pour toutes les dépendances
arad il donc cette fois ci on va
vraiment s'occuper des causes et
construire une vie un sentiment de soit
capable de remplacer le besoin la
cigarette si vous voulez vous avez sur
le site site iraq coach point fr des
séances d'hypnose un b3 de relaxation et
aussi d'autres exercices au tout cas ses
gratte sur ma chaîne youtube
slash haye coaching vous avez également
des séances d'hypnose autour de l'arrêt
de la cigarette autour du développement
de motivation pour arrêter vous
trouverez toute une collection de séance
d'hypnose pratiques que nous avons
développé en collaboration avec le
figaro live et vous trouverez pas
d'autres
d'autres outil bien pratique justement
pourra travailler sur votre bien-être au
quotidien est toujours avec cette idée
d'être le plus simple plus efficace et
le plus utile pour vous et là
aujourd'hui c'est un autre angle
d'attaqué très intéressant qui est de
construire son arrêt de la cigarette
beaubatie vous parce que il faut surtout
pas se lancer dans la cigarette quand on
est mi figue mi raisin si on a envie d'y
aller et on n'a pas envie d'y aller
on peut savoir dès le départ que ls
marche pas donc il faut être sûr qu'on a
envie d'arrêter fois très clair vous pas
être ambivalent et si vous sentez
ambivalent cette séance elle est là pour
vous pour construire quelque chose aux
fermetures surtout ne pas avoir
l'impression pour vous retire quelque
chose mais que vous faites un cadeau à
vous plaît si vous êtes prêts après
cette introduction un petit peu longue
je suis désolé à se lancer cette phase i
dans la séance d'hypnose et bien sûr les
prochaines fois c'était pas saper cette
introduction mais soulève donné quelques
éléments sur le cigarette sur le but
aussi de cette séance pour vous en
compreniez l'intérêt est également
l'intérêt de de répéter la séance tous
les jours si possible ça ou freinent une
dépendance en quelque sorte mais très
très positif cette fois ci parce que
l'hypnose ça donne pas de concert c'est
sûr alors commencé à fixer un point on
va prendre un temps rien que pour vous
un temps pour travailler dans la douceur
dans la joie la tranquillité sur l'arrêt
de la cigarette fixer un point un peu
comme vous le faites quand vous fumez
c'est à dire d'ailleurs les paupières un
peu mi closes
et puis regardez le avec douceur et ma
voix vous accompagner et vous allez
pouvoir vous rencontrer fur et à mesure
que vous avez en vous des ressources qui
vous permet d'être infiniment mieux dans
votre corps dans votre esprit que ce que
vous apporte le cirad et sens la crypto
c'est assez formidable
c'est une joie gratuite c'est un bien
être c'est un apprentissage du cac alors
il n'y a pas d'efforts à faire surtout
ça aussi c'est important
parfois on fume un peu pour compenser le
stress des efforts pour protester un peu
pour faire la grève
alors là cette fois c'est un temps
vraiment que pour vous un temps égoïste
c'est très bien comme ça alors commencé
à fixer un point alors regardé avec un
regard doux et un moment les yeux se
fermeront 5 vous entendez ma voix même
si à certains moments
certains mots certaines phrases ou ses
chapeaux ronds et peu importe le moment
où fermaient les yeux dans ce décompte
de 5
fait que deux fois en fois développerez
capacités entrées de plus en plus en
transe je voudrais que dans les pelouses
la tendance à la fois se dresser au
parti
consciente soi même aussi la partie
inconsciente à l'esprit inconscient les
sensations du corps deviennent plus
présente
la cigarette ceci souvent un plaisir un
plaisir du corps une satisfaction
là vous allez apprendre vous sentir bien
dans votre corps sans avoir besoin de
faire quoi que ce soit en particulier et
pour accompagner cette évolution est
parce que n'arrête la cigarette vous
permettre de retrouver la joie de bien
respirer cette impression c'est
formidable de respirer comme un homme
libre
une femme libre se sentir qu'on n'est
pas obligé d'anticiper le moment il
faudra acheter des cigarettes sortir
comment peut marcher monter des
escaliers vivraient plus d'énergie et
mais même avec plus d'énergie
c'est pour ça que je vous invite à
prendre deux inspirations profondes pour
sentir à quel point c'est bon de
respirer librement et au fur et à mesure
des jo alors que vous répéterez cette
séance et que vous diminuerez les
cigarettes vous sentirez comme votre
respiration va se libérer de plus en
plus ce sera votre première récompense
simplement bien inspiré et le goût des
aliments
les odeurs autour de vous qui vont se
réveiller comme qui devient sourd fur et
à mesure le remarque pas forcément il en
va de même avec la cigarette on oublie
ce que c'est de pouvoir vivre faire ce
qu'on veut sans compter les minutes
entre chaque cigarette on oublie ce que
cela fait de pouvoir apprécier vraiment
le coup d'un plat l'impression qu'on a
quand on est dans la nature dans un bar
gay que l'on peut respirer
à pleins poumons et cette sensation
précieuse d'énergie de bien-être il ya
un vrai cadeau arrêter la cciad
il faut simplement que votre inconscient
le père soir pour qu'ils acceptent au
fur à mesure de diminuer votre
consommation
et vous voyez pendant que vous pensez
s'accroche et se décrochent vos
aspirations elle aussi est devenue plus
profondes
le cas je vous sentez donc cet art
cannes vrai que vous inspirez quelle
différence entre se taire naturellement
frais et pur et cette terre qui soulage
certes cette fumée qui soulage mais qui
en même temps donnée à bush à côté par
une respiration moins profonde avec la
cigarette
là non c'est une vraie du respiration
calme landes
il vous permet d'entrer de plus en plus
au centre de votre bien-être et c'est ce
que va devenir l'hymne aux nouveaux
votre source de bien-être laissant aucun
inconvénient
sans aucune brive asio jean seguin
effort tout ce que l'on fait avec trop
d'efforts on a band alors aujourd'hui
vous allez construire son effort votre
changement 4 et d'autres sensations
s'installe à rome
cette sensation agréable à lors d'un
débat des gens de tout le corps entier
de votre attention s'éloignera de la
cigarette et plus il se rapprochera de
toutes les choses importantes de votre
vie c'est comme lorsqu'on appelé
supportable on se remet à parler avec sa
famille on se remet à envisager de
nouvelles activités a pensé arriver
c'est pareil quand on laisse la
cigarette il ya toute une partie de vous
qui se libère à qui pense à la belle
promenade que vous pourrez faire ses
activités que vous aimez que vous ne
prenez plus le temps de faire ça
s'appelle la liberté cigarette c'est une
chaîne des menottes
quelque chose qui vous contraint
qui dirige de cigarettes ou vous donnez
pas ça dépend
c'est pas si facile d'aragon rassure
c'est vous qui déciderez et sur la durée
pour que cela tienne il faut que et
votre inconscient votre conscience soit
d'accord pour arrêter j'ai pour
construire quelque chose de mieux à la
place leur centre et votre attention sur
le poids du corps le colle aux yeux le
fauteuil la chaise de libre et bob
canapé celui-ci solidement ancré sur le
sol
leseur slim engrais jeu la vie la vie
solidement ancré sur la terre la tête en
grès au système solaire le système
solaire est ancré dans la galaxie la
galaxie ancrée dans l'univers l'univers
vous créer dans le temps le temps créant
vous tandis que vous en créant en transe
cet état de pure bien-être 3 je me fais
penser une histoire que j'ai entendu
quelque part l'histoire d'un homme qui
avait décidé de rompre avec la cigarette
soirée lui dire
tu sais je ne m'en porte que des ennuis
je suis toujours obligé d'obéir
je pense sans arrêt à toi sont des
postes d ailleurs si je fais le bilan
des temps passés avec toi c'est
peut-être fois par jour que je
t'apprécie vannes en matin est ce que je
vois pas prendre simplement l'outil café
ou un thé le midi toujours soir date je
reste du temps sans mauvais jeux centre
ne te haré plus la mienne je sens son
auteur est plus seul
autour de moi et même quand tu n'es pas
là je sens son auteur je suis ton
esclave du départ l'on a mis la
cigarette lui répondit c'est vrai tout
ce que tu dis est regard de ce que je
t'apporte dépose à temps pour toi
impression peut-être fausse pub pression
des temps à ça - tu peux dire merde à
tous ceux qui voudraient te faire
arrêter la cia je ne te débarrassera pas
de moi je reviendrai alors cet homme
intelligemment lüthi écoute fait prendre
une pause
alors ils se promenaient il travailla
il aima il fut de nouvelles choses parce
que bien sûr elle avait un tout petit
peu plus d'argent
les découvrir de nouvelles passions et
puis même si de temps en temps il allait
revoir cette cigarette vient faire
mesure il sentait qu'il avait de moins
en moins besoin d'elle bien bonjour il
oublia d'aller la voir
et ce fut un homme lima et à saumur sur
l'anti gang sans pression son fatigue
son effort avait retrouvé sa liberté ne
se rendit compte qu'il s'était fait le
cadeau d'une vie libre loin de toute
aliénation qu'il avait trouvé de
nouvelles passions de nouvelles manières
d'être bien et que c'était quittant un
poison quotidien qu'il avait découvert
le centre de son propre bonheur il
compris aussi qu'il avait perdu du temps
se soucier cette chose futile il le fit
à son rythme et de luffy pour lui c'est
un la cicad pas pour les autres
il devient tous heures il le fit en
accord avec lui même et c'est pour ça
qu'ils triomphent or présenterait plus
intense parce que lorsque l'on entend
une histoire ensuite on va tous vous
accompagne l'esprit
peu à peu on voit comme lorsqu'on était
enfant qu'on vous raconter une histoire
le soir du calme s'installe est d'abord
de penser disparaissait à mesure que la
voix de notre peuple romain nous
raconter cette histoire de thales
indique d'enregistrement portent en tout
cas il ya dans l'histoire possibilité de
s'accrocher à quelque chose qui nous
fait voyager
il ya quelque chose de magique dans une
histoire est mort
c'est ce qui constitue la pensée et move
regretté en nous et vivre des mondes
sera connue des mondes glace simples
paroles du narrateur permet de créer
alors oui les histoires font voyager oui
l'histoire vont aller davantage entre 2
alors que vos pensées s'accroche
décroche s'accroche se décrochent les
yeux fermés maintenant s'ils ne le sont
pas depuis longtemps
c'est dans une transe agréable si le
permis bateau à se faire soi même être
simplement bien sans avoir besoin tels
trop simple cas bien sans avoir besoin
de sa fumée
de son âpreté son utilité être bien tout
simplement
et pendant que les pensées s'accroche
décroche sa crosse du crash votre
respiration devient plus profonde plus
call vous pouvez sentir mon tir sentir
toujours là quelle manière le corps
connaît le chemin de la transe et de
jour en jour elle mesure que vous
pratiquez si possible chaque jour les
binômes vous développer cette capacité
très bien c'est très bien comme ça
maintenant
alors que dépenser ce fonds se défend
alors que déjà en vous un niveau
inconscient se développe la conception
envie d'une vie sans cigarette est empli
de bien d'autres choses
alors que les pensées se font ce défunt
qu'à chaque moment jacques vient temps
d'oublier une passion pour en accueillir
d'autres alors qu'au fond de nous se
trouve la possibilité de tous nos
changements de toutes nos décisions
alors qu'il suffit de se croire capable
de faire pour le faire alors qu'il
suffit de se réinventer pour oublier
l'inutile
vous n'êtes plus profondément 30
et santé quelques instants cette
respiration sont là vraiment vous pouvez
l'associer par exemple avec un petit
geste gérer le pouce contre l'index par
exemple à chaque fois que vous
reprendrez cette respiration ses rangs
ce pouces contre 7 un texte qu une sorte
de mémento de rabais d'aide-mémoire un
noeud dans un mouchoir retrouverez tout
ce bien-être que vous avez maintenant
cela voudrait dire dans ces moments aux
zones envie de prolonger votre liberté
son assiette ce moment vous aurez envie
d'être fiers de vous et de prouver que
vous êtes libre et bien se calme vous
permettra d'aller jusqu'aux et de
décider ce n'est pas l'homme qu'il fait
pour l'assiette
ce n'est finalement pas la cia qui est
fait pour l'homme non plus mais il ya en
effet ne sert à rien à rien
et l'important c'est ce qui dans votre
vie va servir à être bien être heureux
et l'hypnose quotidienne en fera partie
quelle belle et saine dépendance que ça
qu'on peut arrêter si l'on veut
maintenant j'aimerais demander à votre
esprit inconscient de choisir le toit
qui correspond le plus à la réponse oui
et puis dès qu'il aura choisi de faire
un petit mouvement avec se doit par et
ce presque inconscient imperceptible
comme ça c'est très bien
je vais maintenant demander à votre
esprit inconscient de faire apparaître
une des choses qui vous retenait
d'arrêter la cigarette un bénéfice
secondaire un plaisir en tout cas ce que
vous considérez instant être un plaisir
c'était qu'il l'a retrouvé il va point
me faire le signe oui
très bien l'esprit inconscient n'est pas
masochiste inconscient vous protège
dents tout le comportement il ya
toujours une intention positive tout à
l'heure je vous parlais de toutes ces
bonnes mauvaises raisons de fumer il ya
toujours l'intention positive se sentir
bien prendre une pause maîtriser sa vie
est trop bien fait et je ne mentais à
votre esprit inconscient
de discerner l'intention positive qui se
cache se déguise sous ce bénéfice
secondaire
derrière cette chaîne qui vous retenait
avant à la cigale dès qu'il l'a trouvé
et le voit le signe oui
diaby et maintenant je vais demander à
notre esprit inconscient de trouver deux
ou trois manières fossiles bénéfique
pour vous qui pourrait davantage
correspondre à cette intention positive
elle qui vous feront mon avantage de
bien je te sais deux ou trois manières
de penser et d'agir de ces deux ou trois
nouveaux plaisirs
il gardera ce qu'il veut et mettre en
place ce qu'ils souhaitent au rythme qui
le souhaitent et ce sera le bon rythme
puisque ce sera votre rythme et votre
choix
suivez ces deux minutes ont précisé ces
deux ou trois nouvelles manières de
faire de penser on sait deux ou trois
nouvelles manières de se faire du bien
très bien
maintenant je vais demander à votre
esprit inconscient de noter alors que
vous êtes bien dans ce calme et que vous
sentez les changements qu'ils installent
de séance en séance en vaut deux notés
de 0 à 10
votre motivation votre motivation votre
envie sincère wahedi l'assiette 0 au
bout
cindy n'a aucune mais ce n'est pas
possible 10 si vous êtes totalement
prêts pour arrêter et dès que le chiffre
sera pareil niveau inconscient voit les
ignorer très bien j'ai maintenant je
vais demander à votre esprit inconscient
qu'elle soit nombre de cigarettes que
vous ferez demain je vais lui demander
de donner un chiffre réaliste chiffres
que vous allez pourra respecter si
demain votre motivation n'est pas assez
forte
alors ce n'est pas aujourd'hui vous
pouvez définir que vous restera même
nombre de cigarettes
personne ne vous force tête entre vous
et vous pendant que votre inconscient à
définir le nombre de cigarettes que vous
fait marrer demain celle
que vous prendrez en moins bien
j'aimerais juste vous raconter petite
vérité autour de cigarettes
êtes vous déjà demandé pourquoi pensez
qu'a été aussi forte
tu parce que bien souvent vous avez
tenté de l'arrêter d'un coup et la
dépendance physique s'est fait alors
sentir le stress la lettre alors ensuite
toutes les bases s'excuse ou une
mauvaise excuse on a pourtant mais c'est
compréhensible c'est normal c'est humain
et puis au moment vous aviez arrêté tout
ce qu'il vous apporte est apparue en
creux dans votre vie augmente et
seulement et comme vous avez connu un
échec
deux échecs trois échecs c'est fini par
croire que c'était elle qui commandait
alors que simplement votre niveau
d'ambition n'était pas assez faim votre
envie lui clairement votre envie et puis
le nombre de cigarettes arrêter trop
important
celui qui va aller loin ménage sa
monture et vous pouvez tout à fait vous
débarrasser le siet une cigarette à la
voix et ce sera certes non pas
dépendance biologique qui vous retiendra
par ce lundi 20 sont un peu nicotine
sera complètement dérisoire donc combien
de cigarettes et vous fumez en juillet
le givre n'dré bien très bien très bien
et maintenant que cette décision est
installé à mon goût je vais demander à
votre esprit inconsciente ou faire vivre
à l'avance de quelle manière votre
journée à se dérouler avec cette
cigarette ou ses cigarettes dans mon
avis rté la joie sentiment de liberté
que vous aurez puis toutes ces choses là
que gignac sur vous de vous diriger vers
l'arrêt de la cigarette pendant une
petite minute il va vous faire vivre à
l'avant cette journée les sondes
sensations les images vont se préciser
avec cela à se cristalliser en poupe
cette décision libre
on c'est parfait et maintenant je
demande une bonne chose à votre esprit
inconscient je lui ai demandé de vous
faire vivre à l'avance ce à quoi
ressemblera votre vie une fois que la
cigarette sera parti et je lui ai
demandé d'accès
cette expérience sur l'un des points
positifs qui remplacera d'une manière
très favorable ce qu'elle vous apporter
avant d'une manière des forts mais avec
plus d'inconvénients que davantage ce
sera peut-être fait vivre à l'avancé
nouvelle liberté
ce sera possiblement le fait de respirer
et enfin de ressentir de sentir ce sera
peut-être un élan vital du sport
l'énergie envie d'agir ce sera peut-être
un voyage
gagner à sept sa disparition peu importe
votre esprit inconscient c'est ce qui
est important et pendant les prochaines
minutes il va vous faire vivre dans le
détail et votre vie sans cigarette au
tour de cette chose merveilleuse que
vous allez expérimentés et vivre si vous
désirez sortir de là tant sa brève
remontée de 1 à 5
mais si vous décidez de rester dans cet
état de calme pour pouvoir par exemple
dormir ou vous détendre encore un peu
laissé ensuite votre imagination et vos
rêves vous guide et vous laisse emporter
est tout d'abord votre inconscient venir
à l'avance l'énorme bénéfices aux
avantages merveilleux changement un
cadeau que vous aurez dans votre vie
sans cigarette
elles sont des sensations se préciser
je vous accompagne ainsi non
alors que se poursuivent en vous les
changements merveilleux de l'inconscient
que se poursuit la sérénité
comme ça bien en transit vers l'avant
une vie mais à mes yeux sans s'y arrête